[Music]
on behalf of the stanford graduate
school of business i'd like to welcome
you to view from the top we are so
excited to have you here
thank you for having me we have so much
to learn from you here at the gsb about
your business savvy and your tenacity
and building a truly fantastic company
so i'd like to start today with the
origin of honest so much of the company
is built upon your personal experience
as a child with health challenges and as
a mom
who struggled to find products that were
affordable and eco-friendly
for your own children so can you tell us
about how these pain points led you to
developing a business solution
yeah gladly
you know i think
it really was for me
um
filling a need and finding a
a real opportunity to show up
for not just for myself but for many
people in a way that i think
i i
i was seeing that um
companies that make products that really
interact with you every single day
and could have an effect on your health
and well-being over time
um they just weren't really considering
i think holistically
your health and wellness
as the the top priority and for me i
just felt like our health and wellness
like when you go through your life
and you are thinking of quality of life
and thriving
and when your health
is compromised
and your health and wellness is
compromised in any way shape or form
it's really difficult
to then
live a life where you can thrive and be
happy
and live life to the fullest so when i
was a child and i was very sick and i
you know
was constantly reminded um that i wasn't
like others and i was isolated i had
severe asthma
um and allergies and every time i had
an allergy to something it actually
triggered my asthma and i was put in the
hospital on steroids
um i was in the hospital
i would say at least three or four times
a year
for a week to two weeks
doing steroid treatments and breathing
treatments and dealing with pneumonia
and bronchitis and
every cold turned into pneumonia so it
was just like a whole situation
but i wanted to like play baseball and
soccer and be a normal kid and so i
would go on the soccer field with the
breathing machine
and i would have that next to me
um
i also had like
kidney issues and um cysts on and um
many different other surgeries on top of
that and all of this like before i was
11.
so i just dealt with a lot of health
issues and when i was pregnant with my
first daughter uh about 13 years ago
i had an allergic reaction and i had
pretty much like stayed away from the
things that that were causing reactions
and i started to really create
sort of like this subconsciously this
safe environment where i didn't i wasn't
exposed to a lot of the things that
would trigger
um my
allergies or asthma
and then when i was
um
pregnant with honor i had an allergic
reaction to a detergent that was
marketed to
parents to use on their baby's clothing
and my mom said she used it on me and i
didn't know very many moms
and when i had this allergic reaction i
i got like a flood of the memories of me
as a kid and having all of these health
issues
and i was like oh my god what if my baby
is like me what if she has these
these sort of issues and and it really
kind of shaped who i am and i think it
builds character to go through
difficulties but if it could be avoided
like i like let's avoid them you know
um
i also was dealing with sorry there's a
play
can avoid planes over here
um
my mother got cancer when she was um i
believe she was like 23 22 or 23 and had
to have a full hysterectomy
and meaning she couldn't have children
anymore and her cancer was
environmentally caused because there was
nothing genetically
that
was linked to that
so when i sort of looked i i like took
sort of a reflection on like my
childhood my mom's health and wellness
now i'm bringing this little person into
the world and thinking about quality of
life in a different way i was told i
wasn't allowed to eat like deli meats
and i couldn't you know
use my
retinol on my face
because it could possibly affect the
baby and and her health and wellness so
i started looking at ingredients and
thinking about my health differently and
hers obviously and i learned about lots
of untested and potentially harmful
chemicals
that we use and are exposed to on the
daily
and a lot of it is in beauty products
hair skin products makeup products
fragrances
home detergents
and so then i was like oh my goodness
every single day we're being exposed to
all of these potentially harmful
chemicals and we don't even know it and
we don't even know how it's affecting
our health so then i was looking at
i looked at data and was trying to
understand the research around the rise
of
illness
and there was a pretty like
parallel path in the industrialization
of these chemicals and then being put
into
consumer products and beauty products
and and that rise um really paralleled
the rise of
many illnesses that people um are
dealing with from
because their hormone disruptors and
they're endocrine disruptors
and they're linked to things like
various cancers learning disabilities
um
uh and also like the uh the way that it
affects your hormones um it's basically
like
giving
your um your body
steroids
um and it really screws up your hormones
men and women um the exposure to a lot
of these chemicals so i was like how do
we not know about this and how is this
even allowed in this country with all of
the you know shouldn't there be a
governing
sort of
practice or rules or standards and in
the uk they actually make companies test
chemicals for safety before they're even
allowed to be brought into
um the marketplace in personal care and
beauty and in this country
the way that the system is set up is it
has to be proven to kill enough people
before they'll even look into it being
dangerous
and so i was like what so basically like
we're just being tested on
um and i was like that is so messed up
and then people who live in
um
uh
sort of like different circumstances
where they don't um they can't
necessarily control their environment
and their shopping um habits
because they you know they're just
trying to survive and they're living
paycheck to paycheck like like i grew up
and a lot of black and brown families as
well
are um
disproportionately affected by the
exposure to a lot of these chemicals
and so i was just like whoa and so i um
legislated for chemical reform to try
and at least get our standards in this
country to be more like europe
um and
uh a lot sorry not legislated i lobbied
for the legislation for chemical reform
excuse me and i did it twice um and
basically as you know during covid um
our health has been politicized
and it's basically whatever opinion
someone wants to decide as truth becomes
the truth verse facts and so um i was
like wow we this shouldn't be about a
political party this is just common
sense and human health
anyway i'm frustrated with
the system um i was like well um how can
i create a solution for people that
really has like the ethics and values
around
human health
safety
also
thinking about the planet
and sustainability
and then um obviously i think the last
and most important piece of the puzzle
is um really showing up for people and
meeting their needs no matter where they
live in the country it shouldn't be like
oh i i you know can only if i afford the
most expensive things and so i can shop
at like a whole foods or whatever type
of grocery store but everyone else is
sort of left out and i was like that
just isn't fair and also i felt like
there weren't a lot of companies that
stood for health and wellness
um
that also like spoke my language
i don't know i just feel like i love
beauty in in design and um i love
beautiful things in the home and i just
felt like there was a way to kind of
like show up in a beautiful way but
still have
the ethos and the values and the ethics
that i have as a person so that's really
where the the business came from and the
idea
and that's how it started
well i love the intergenerational aspect
of it of watching your mom go through
something experiencing something
yourself and then trying to create a
solution for your children that's
obviously a really wonderful brand story
but obviously not everyone was sold in
the beginning so i'm curious
how did your business pitch evolve as
you experienced some initial naysayers
or some no's
yeah i mean i think you have to know
your audience
know their capacity
and originally i was pitching this note
this idea
to start this business with people in
entertainment
not knowing that the very business model
in entertainment is incoming calls and
licensing deals
right
um and it isn't starting from the ground
up and investing in a concept now i
think hollywood has gotten a little bit
more savvy and i and i would say you
know the success of my company has moved
the business
to be a little bit more open to
different ways of operating
i also think that because uh
the
shift in access to content
and the internet
and habits
um changing and consuming
has changed so dramatically over the
last
i mean 20 years but really 10 years
so the business hollywood has had to
also try and figure out where they fit
in that um and i think they're still
challenged um because they're holding on
to a lot of the old sort of systems
um but
yeah so i i guess i i was pitching this
idea to the wrong audience that's first
and foremost then i started pitching it
around to
different people outside of my scope and
i would say you know while um
as an entrepreneur you're so excited and
you you see your
end goal
right and you know you're moving towards
that end goal
you have to make it palatable
for
what can happen here and now and today
so it's like well you want to sell the
dream of
this is going to be a global brand that
stands for
you know the health and well-being of
people in the planet
and we're going to make
not only build community
and educate people on how they can live
a better life but we're also going to
create the solution for them
and it's going to be in various
categories
around home detergents
around bath and body products
around baby products and around
skin
and beauty products for me i had to
distill my idea
down to the thing that was trendy and
hot in the moment
where investors were excited to invest
into these new
business models
and i knew that i didn't want to take
this
concept to a retailer because i didn't
want the retailer to then because when
you take your concept and your idea and
you build inside of a retailer's
environment um you they
they essentially get to
take the reins and mold it into what
fits into their business model and you
often will compromise on your values
especially when you are right out the
gate i also knew i wanted there to be a
charity component you know um and i
thought that was just really important
and i also really wanted there to be
diversity and inclusion
just embedded in
the values and the practices of who we
are so
all of those things
i would say are just very new concepts
um in a plan and
especially back in 10 years ago
um people hadn't really seen successful
businesses that have values
um
like that i mean there's like there
there were very few and far between
um
that hit on all of those things
and so i had to figure out you know like
know your audience
distill the concept down to what is
you know hot in the moment that people
are excited to invest behind
and um make it you know get your ella
elevator pitch down because i had like a
hundred page deck with like you know
everything from like
home paints and furnishings and
detergents all the way through to
you know
beauty products and and then brands that
sit in different price points and i
it's distributed i mean i had the whole
caboodle and so i had to really distill
it down to at the time what was hot was
a predictable subscription business
model
um and i partnered with essentially the
guy that had
paved the way for that business model to
um
come to life he he um founded legalzoom
and another business called
shoedazzle
um and so
i partnered with him
and pitched him the business and he
turned me down
um and then he came back about 18 months
later and i pitched him again and at
that point he had had a kid and saw his
wife change her beauty habits
change what she allowed in the house
throughout all of their detergents in
their home the cleaning products and um
and basically was shopping from you know
a very
small and curated um
set to provide a healthy environment for
their their little child and so he was
like oh my goodness okay so
people do change when they have kids and
they start thinking differently about
ingredients
chemical exposures the planet and and
those types of values um i would say now
um and so so when i partnered with him
then we basically went
and um
pitched you know sand hill on sand hill
like five
uh or six companies and uh vcs and we
got five term sheets by the end of the
day and i was eight and a half months
pregnant and i was told by my doctor i
wasn't allowed to fly anymore and that
was my second child i was pregnant
because it took me actually three years
to get to that point
um
and
yeah i think i think it's like it's you
have to be very humble
if you want to be an entrepreneur or be
part of a business know what you know
what know what you don't know and then
um
you know
surround yourself with people that
really um support your strengths and
your weaknesses
yeah i love that point about knowing
your audience and how
his
his life circumstances changed how he
acted as an audience member to receiving
your pitch and just that little moment
of his wife experiencing exactly what
you're talking about was all they really
needed to
to see as a benefit for the company
so at business school in all of our
classes we're constantly constantly
reading case studies
uh to learn about pivotal moments in a
company's history uh so we talked a
little bit about the pitch we can fast
forward to honestco is now an amazing
company
what do you think would be the
inflection point that you would choose
if the gsb were to do a case study
it's interesting
i would say going from
uh and operating from a like startup
um and
you know that that's like a high growth
startup with that sort of
high growth business model
and
really transitioning into
a more steady state
growth
business model
and
uh
building the
foundational principles to operate
like a um a business that could be
around for a hundred years
because the people that you
bring in and that can get capital
um
to
start a company are very different
people that usually i would say 99 of
the time it's usually a very different
team than
that can operate um and build out
foundational principles for a company
that could stick around for 100 plus
years
i love that and speaking of teams
actually an instrumental part of your
team is your current ceo i'm curious how
did you find him how did you how did he
convince you that he was the right
person
that he was really going gonna be able
to carry your vision forward as ceo nick
uh
worked at clorox and actually um you
know when we were
starting the business and when we had
such high growth and being a digital
first business and building community it
was such a different approach and the
values and the ethics around health and
wellness again was also such a different
um in in the way that we went about it
was such a different approach to the way
a lot of the big cpg companies operate
and so we've had all of the big
companies
knock on our door and you have to take
those meetings and so he had um
spent time with us and looked at us
you know years before
and
really sort of like
understood our business model
and then when we were at a time to bring
in a new team to really like build those
foundational principles
um
i think because he we had he had
historic data
and
understood
the mental model of like what needed to
be true and also he had done it with
burt's bees
when they brought burt's bees into
clorox
and um
you know he really has a very like
creative approach
to um
business and i think
you know you can't have someone who's so
um
stuck into what they know but you need
to have someone who's really genuinely
open and curious
to building out what the business needs
at that moment and he really felt like
he um was grounded in um
in
and having conviction about that but
then also i would say
the other big piece of it is he really
lived this life these values um are very
meaningful to him and his family he's a
father of four two sets of twins
and um his
wife and him and the kids they live
very much
these values and these are the types of
products they have in their home and
this is um you know how they live their
life so just those the purpose and the
mission of the company
um really resonated with him so
i love that well an amazing moment uh
that you had last year was when you took
the company public so congratulations on
that yeah i'm curious did the ipo feel
like a moment to pause and appreciate
all of your compliment accomplishments
or was it a wake-up call that new
challenges and opportunities were ahead
of you
you know for me it was like
both um i would say that every time we
hit
a different sort of transition or
milestone
i
at this point i feel like i've been
through it all
at all um and you'll see guys when you
start your own businesses
about
um and yeah it almost felt like
we're starting from zero again and
building
the foundation of what it means to be
and operate like a public company and
now like we're building those um
building blocks and those foundational
principles again but in this new space
i love that
so i would be remiss if i didn't mention
your your previous role uh and current
still role in hollywood and
where where i learned at least at your
talent agency caa branding your personal
brand is everything and i'm curious what
learning's carried over from that world
to the business world um i'm now at uta
um but i
yeah i would say that your personal
brand
as
someone in hollywood but then even
someone
like you or any of you guys sitting
there um you can't
you guys are living in a very kind of um
it's sort of like welcome to the party
of being exposed um you guys are living
a very um digital reality
and um and people can
um unearth
who you are and your past and
your life if anything is much more um on
display
i would say than any other generation
and will continue to
be on display and so where you go
in your life and how who you surround
yourself with
and how you align yourself
along the way will have an impact on
your future opportunities
and so i think for me i was always very
cognizant of that from a very early age
and i think it's just something to be
mindful of you know depending on what
your aspirations are
um making sure that you own all of your
decisions
and
and you are honest with yourself
um along the way and i'm not saying
don't make
don't be fearful
but just be aware
and i think a lot of people
don't always think
of
step three four and five
um they just see the shiny penny in
front of them
and they get excited
um but i always think of three four and
five because i didn't have a backup plan
i didn't grow up with a safety net i had
to create my own so i i just i think i
just operated with that in mind when i
was building out um and or making any
decision from age 12 on
right yeah and important to note that it
started so young and uh social media and
everything has changed so much and
you've been you've been adapting since
you were 12 which was is amazing
i'd love to talk about the future of
where honest is going you recently
launched the daily defense collection
which is a line of skin care products
designed to defend against environmental
pollutants which is so incredibly
important i'm curious how do you see
those screens who knew these screens
could affect your skin oh my god
the screens that are currently blasting
stuff at us right now all day
i'm curious how you predict future
trends and
continue to build products for the
future
no a lot of it comes from
i think trusting my gut and
my intuition
it's weird like i don't necessarily need
mckinsey data
to substantiate
you know where
i like what i feel or what i know
and oftentimes
i feel like i can be and not everything
is a home run but
if you will need a
bane or mckinsey study to validate um
your marketplace opportunity it's often
a little too late
um because you know the trendsetters did
it
three years before it became a trend
that it would even become a case study
or a study at all
um
and so i would say that keeping your
feet on the ground
and really understanding
the pain point or the needs that you are
filling
in whatever business you are creating
for me it's being
very consumer-centric
um and and very personal
you know i always start from that place
and then i do my research from there
um
around you know sort of like what other
companies are doing things like this or
what other um
like our sensitive skin care line all of
us want benefits in our skincare we want
you know brightening and we want you
know
um our fine lines to go away and we want
you know our discoloration to go away
you know we want to have those those um
skin care benefits in our skin care we
just don't we're not looking for
something that's just sort of like put
this on your face and it'll be a shield
and nothing and then there you go
and it's better than having like this
rash now i'm allergic to a lot of those
products even the gentle ones that the
dermatologists recommend so i couldn't
even use those so i was like how about
we have
a
skin care routine that works for people
with really sensitive skin
but actually like
does something for you
and my cat
our head chemist she has very sensitive
skin as well
and and so that's you know just
something where we were like hey if you
get rashes
if you have sensitive skin a lot of
people who break out a lot also have
very sensitive skin
um there's nothing for you
and
um and you're sort of just left in the
dust
so i was like this would be a cool one
to be able to create a full solution
where you can have exfoliation
brightening
um
really hydrating
we have a lightweight moisturizer and a
heavier moisturizer so it's for
different types of skin
it doesn't clog your pores you know all
of those things so
that's another a lot of it comes from
the personal and then
you know you look at the marketplace and
you see how many people are doing it and
then there's other things where you're
just like hey this is table stakes you
need to have
x or you need to have y in order to
really like
be in this category
so it's a blend
yeah i love how your ideation process
for new products kind of always goes
back to how you started honest itself
which was based on problems that you
experienced yourself and obviously
you're not the only one to experience
those right
so we started this talk with a tick tock
you are
a parent to gen z kids uh and a marketer
and i'm curious because we are always
talking about gen z and i feel like
articles are always gen z this gen z
that uh as a as a parent and as a
marketer what is something you think
we're getting wrong about that
generation
i think we try to over complicate it
and
the gap of understanding feels so wide
and i think there's sort of like a
frustration
in the way that like
they're moving at a pace
and are going to continue to move at a
pace that
is beyond
any other generation just because in the
digital age you know before you had to
reimagine your business sort of like
every five years
and then i would say about 10 years ago
when i launched honest it was like oh no
you've got to reimagine your business
and how you operate and the way that you
do it like every three years now i would
say it's like every year you've got to
reassess and reevaluate and reimagine
um
i think
that because they're so young
maybe it's hard to
trust that they know what they're
talking about
and allow them to
take
some leadership
and hand the baton over like know what
you don't know and also like
if something is meant to appeal to them
it doesn't necessarily need to appeal to
me
or to
you
right um and sometimes it'll appeal to
me and it'll appeal to you but i think
you know um
that is one thing that like i feel like
when you're running a business or when
you're trying to understand
a demographic
you feel like you should also be on the
same page as them but it's totally okay
that they think the way that they think
and they respond to things differently
than you and you don't need to take it
personally and know that it's okay for
you to have your differences what i
appreciate about
gen z
um and i actually don't think of it as
being an issue is just that they love
authenticity
they are values driven
um
and
the brand values are meaningful to them
and the more that you
really um show up authentically the
better i think the businesses that are
in trouble
in appealing to gen z are the ones that
are trying to be tricky
um
well a clear theme of today for sure is
knowing your audience and uh you clearly
know this audience as well
uh
so much about honest co is educating the
consumer you've been doing that since
before you even started
the company and as many of us here are
looking to start new businesses some of
them might be quite complicated deep
tech web3 what have you
what lessons can you share about what
works best in educating your consumer
make it entertaining
if it's boring for you to
watch it's going to be boring for
anybody to watch
like you know what i mean if it's boring
to read it it's going to be boring for
everyone
um
i think more and more because we have so
much
it's almost like the volume of content
it is so
um daunting and overwhelming and is only
going to get more daunting as we start
to
integrate
ar into our day-to-day
and as we integrate more of like
the web 3
into our day-to-day with wearables and
all of that
um
we're going to
almost have information overload
and so having really
short and sweet pithy
ways of communicating no matter if
you're a software company or not
um
even a b2b
i would say when work you know choosing
partners for
you know b2b type of partners or
something that will help a function for
um
you know in our company in some form or
fashion
we're always looking at how difficult is
it to integrate usually the difficulty
has to do with how boring it is
to
to understand it and to apply it you
know you making your
materials as
consumer-facing as possible
is important even for
software companies or b2bs so
that's great advice thank you we've
shared incredible advice with all of us
and we're all super grateful for your
time and you're also an incredible model
for so many founders from
underrepresented groups and for women so
thank you for being here today i could
go on forever but we do have some
questions from the audience so i would
like to turn it over to our first
question from jy
hi jessica um i'm originally from
singapore and moved to the bay to attend
the gsb um i'm an aspiring entrepreneur
so super excited to be here and my
question for you is um what was some of
your biggest fears in building the
honors co and how do you overcome that
maybe my biggest fear was not connecting
with
my truth in a way
and allowing people who had
trust and a history in
business um
sort of
take over the narrative or
run the business in a direction that i
intuitively knew wasn't right
and
um
i felt
impostor syndrome because i didn't have
a traditional business
degree and background
um and so it took me a hot minute to
really like step into my skin
as a person
um and i think the more i've trusted my
intuition and my gut and stood in my
truth
the better i feel
in everything right in business and and
in life
but i would say that was my
my biggest fear
it's scary when you've never done it
before right
absolutely thanks for sharing
hi jessica um my name is kristen lim and
i am also an aspiring entrepreneur um
looking to do something within the
beauty space
um i'm also a power user of honest
products and i can't live without my
magic bomb
um and i'm so impressed with honest
growth in just the first year
um you've achieved 12 million in revenue
and this grew to a staggering 150
million in revenue just two years later
and at the gsb we use the lean startup
methodology for product ideation and i
know from the talk
that you talked about honest product
ideation
starting from your own pain points but
i'm curious as honest continue to scale
how the product ideation process evolved
yeah i mean i would say that
it it started from a very pure place
and then
i allowed i sort of gave away my power
and my truth for a little while and i
allowed for it to be
a bit of a mosh pit
of
everyone wanting to chime in and not
having clear
roles and responsibilities and
boundaries defined
and
you know i think i'm still a work in
progress when it comes to
that but
um
the biggest thing is really like again
trusting your instincts
knowing what needs to be true in order
for you to have a real authentic
positioning in the marketplace for me i
knew my gut was telling me from day one
we needed to have an in-house lab
and an in-house team and a regulatory
team and also a sourcing team because
that was the only way we were going to
have
true differentiation
in our formulas that can meet the
standards of conventional
or exceed them and
if i was just going to operate like
other companies
it just there was no way to get there it
was just going to be too many hurdles
and so i went through all the hurdles
right
um but
that is the biggest thing is just know
what needs to be true for you
in order for you to have a real
authentic position and also for you a
reason for you to even exist it's a
crowded marketplace so why are you here
and what are you doing that's materially
different
thank you so much
[Music]
you